school still today young it doesn't look
like an american yearbook this is how
she showed up that's how racist they are
yeah they still won't put me in the hot
the power high school
walk of fame hall of fame hall of fame
really yeah they have a hall of fame
right no one in there has anything
remotely in my credits right right right
one guy played like the violin in some
symphony you know i mean 20 years ago
and he got in to be fair tom delong from
blink 182 isn't on there either yeah
because tom dolan went to my school they
view my high school views my kind of
fame not real
it has to be associated with you know a
guy like michael wang like this is what
does he do yeah like this guy he is a
part of the hall of fame yeah
he's a doctor he's a doctor you know
that's what they view right yeah yeah
but he is chief of ophthalmology yeah i
did the tonight show at 29. let's go
after five years of doing stand-up
that's a big [ __ ] deal a big deal
that's a doctor yeah yeah [ __ ] you yeah
you were a man eight years uh an asian
guy korean dude on a american sketch
show yes for eight years [ __ ] you that's
something too it's right it's huge it's
huge
like what what what the indian girl
what's her name abi ami adoshi what does
she do
pediatric hospitalist yeah they're all
in the medical field right you should
get a doctorate i should get my doctor
and if they don't [ __ ] put me in a
zen i'll i'll never go you know i think
this is just a part of the larger
theme that comedians don't get respected
this may not be yeah may not be a korean
thing like the the other the yearbook
thing was definitely an asian thing yeah
yeah yeah definitely but this could be
just like you know we don't get an oscar
we don't get
any respect there's no yeah there's no
award shows we get slapped yeah
yeah yeah it's also viewed like
like you know strippers
have the same environment right yes you
know patrons drink right there's a it's
always in a nightclub late at night
right it's the same kind of two-drink
minimum it's like same type of childhood
yeah yeah i mean that in many ways yeah
yeah
same kind of traumatic trial or some
sort of issue right and i think we're
not viewed respectfully no we're not
yeah we're not and notice like when like
guys like robin williams and jim carrey
these guys that do get into the
hollywood machine right they generally
don't come back but there are ones that
chris rock they do right right but there
are those
yeah like tim allen just completely
disappeared right right they're like i
got out of whatever that was right right
whereas now
what i love about the young kids now
is they view
stand-up comedy
as the beyond be all end-all
you know i mean if they can do it
in this field that they made it
where i was conditioned that i had to do
something else outside of stand-up but i
think i'm going the other way i think i
am
very proud of being being coming are you
very proud very proud very proud of it
yeah i think it's cool you know what it
is it's funny too because i think part
of it is because maybe
certain comedians are a little more edgy
and so then they look down on that and
then the ones that they idolize like uh
that are very clean
those ones end up
raping people
yeah yeah i think there's
it's never the guy who's like crazy or
filthy on stage who's ending who's doing
anything yeah yeah yeah it's always the
clean cut guy who's trying to create an
image yes yeah those ones are always
weird
and even they even if they don't do like
sexual misconduct or anything like that
they're kind of [ __ ] they're like
sadistic or something yeah yeah like in
real life they're real [ __ ] yeah
like
you know is seinfeld a nice guy
yeah is he no i said that sarcastically
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah i've heard he doesn't
like to be touched yeah yeah yeah
there's so much yeah i mean there's just
a weirdness about it yeah i mean
whenever i see him i um
i i think he's a legend and i think he's
a very talented man that's not what i'm
saying but
you know um that's an interesting thing
or unhealthful advice on hopeful advice
with bobby kalila and giannis
uh hey guys great dude thanks man yeah
i'm 34 and married with one child need
your help with your awesome medical
sexual advice i become a vegetarian not
a vegan because i'm a fat ass at heart
and can't survive on lettuce i gain a
lot more energy especially uh sexually i
last longer it gets up and stays hard
longer but i've noticed